okay guys yes are we ready yes
carrie you ready yeah serious face on
yeah let's go
okay on order six couples table two six
and haruka bean soup
make all six pheasants let's go
pheasants in please let's go
now tonight start as a rich sumptuous
hariko bean soup with tiger prawns
now these beans have been soaked
overnight in water and what that does it
actually softens the bean
and makes him cook a lot quicker
in with the bacon onion and carrot
and once you brought it to the ball
quickly cook out for about 25 to 30
minutes
now tiger prawns has his own built-in
cooking gauge when they're raw they're
grey when they're cooked they're nice
and pink
we cook the prawns for 30 seconds in
boiling water and vegetables
we call that a cork bouillon now prawns
are the perfect choice for a seafood
beginner because they're nice and sweet
slightly meaty and so easy to cook
we peel them from the shell when they're
warm because it's a lot easier when
they're warm
get the tail and push with your finger
and thumb and the whole thing just pops
out
once the beans have been drained of its
stock just take a couple of handfuls out
because that's going to be in with the
prawns and the mushrooms the bottom of
the soup
the rest of the beans into the mixer
[Music]
a couple of ladles of bean puree into
the pan
we add our chicken stock
and bring it up to the boil once we
start to boil it we're going to add a
touch of cream
now this comes to the boil for the
exciting part is where we start to froth
the soup
and make it really nice and light
a bit of a chef's thing you don't have
to prop it up but it's just a way of
making it a little bit lighter
and if you don't have a stick mix then
just serve it as a normal white bean
soup nothing wrong with it whatsoever
that's it okay take your ladle out
give it a little buzz kerry give it in
the blessings outside
oh come on
now tonight in the kitchen my three
comment chefs are phil russell and kerry
they've already survived one round in
the f-word kitchen and whoever stays
tonight
will come back to battle it out for a
job in one of my restaurants
okay why are we making two pounds i want
three portions the suit's made to order
you've got four portions there he's got
four portions why don't you do the
garnish
yeah yeah and you do the soup but no
one's talking yeah are you just making
no sense whatsoever so talk to one
another
check the seasoning please taste it
carrot come on
and then set the garnish up here and so
we can start slowly
yeah wait yeah half this table yeah
the garnish for the soup are the tiger
prawns
along with the tiger prawns we've got
these little japanese samoji mushrooms
and we're just going to saute the
mushrooms off get your cloth on the
front here
that's it okay
get some color on the mushrooms first
before you put the prawns in
now we're using a japanese mushroom but
if you're quite frank any mushroom will
work lovely with this
30 seconds for the prawns get your beans
put your beans in with the prawns
and there we have a really nice garnish
right now they've studied off the
garnish yeah just season it
with some fresh parsley
shut up and just listen that's all if
you listen you're gonna do well but
fresh parsley then from there over to
the bowl let's go
okay take your garnish and be generous
with the garnish
your prawns your beans and your
mushrooms
into the plate no just three portions
come on kerry please
wake up just three portions one two
three you're on your fourth oh sorry
garlic so you take half the froth and
half the soup
and you pour it gently over the garnish
yeah
and then you go back to the beginning
yeah let's put a little bit more froth
in there can you just concentrate for me
yeah and try to wake up a little bit
it'll make life a lot easier for you
the customers and me yes good girl
it's not difficult you know that i know
now this is a perfect winter soup
great for the cold nights ahead and
check out the f-word website
for the recipe service please
well it was delicious soup the horns
i'm not sure how they were cooked but
they had a beautiful flavor thumbs up to
gordon really
i'm afraid sorry big suck up but
absolutely he's gorgeous and says his
food
what more can i say
that's why it was easier ladies good
evening
hello how are you veroni i love watching
you in there how was your soup it was
very very good yes
yes thank you no i love pizza food do
you cook at home
i sort of share it because we've got
little kids so whoever puts the kids to
bed doesn't do the cooking
really i'm quite good with the with a
recipe yep but i'm not
my husband's got the flare i haven't got
the flare and what would you say his
pierced the resistance says what's his
favorite dish
my favorite dish that he does is it's
just sea bass baked sea bass
and he does sort of some grilled
vegetables
and then he'll put them in the tray with
the seat bass open the foil and put it
in
sounds a little bit like jamie oliver to
me that one though is he using that
swear word
we're not going to say that you're not
on a particular diet or anything like
that
i don't know how do you keep so fit work
out work out
i mean i basically eat what i want yeah
um because i work out
and that's one very good reason to work
out isn't it
so you can eat what you want yeah but
have you ever been on a diet i did that
work brilliantly i lost six plans in two
weeks amazing
but i was obsessed by bread like if
somebody picked up that piece of bread
over there i'd see you at 500 paces
and they'd be like oh my god they're
using birds
and then i'd say okay i'll have sundays
off so i'd started eating sweets and
bread at seven in the morning
and i'd literally be like pasta you know
until the end of the day it was just
ridiculous there is one negativity
against the sort of
atkins diet you know because it's not
very good for your sex life did you just
say the word sex
in my ear you said about sex in my ear
but does it have a name in my ear
no you can't do things like that to me
oh i'll tell you what it is
well i couldn't poo i mean if you're
going to say sex let's say
poo i couldn't poof hey cooking it was
awful because you don't eat vegetables
and with that hello heinous breath so
obviously
sex life is gonna go out the window
because you can't snog and if you can't
snog you're not gonna have sex
you took me there gordon next on the
menu along with our main course of
pheasant with a fantastic red sauce
the commies start to crack under
pressure you're gonna kill someone you
can't serve raw bacon
and just when i thought things couldn't
get any worse for charles corrin
we sent
[Applause]
okay one minute for the cabbage how long
for your hands one minute let's go
so you can start playing up in 30
seconds jess welcome back to the f-word
time now for the main course
roasted pheasant braised cabbage bread
sauce with devils on horseback
[Music]
pheasant the secret behind cooking this
birth is actually
lining the breasts with some streaky
bacon because it really is a very lean
bird with hardly any fat
thai not too tight a keeps the bacon on
and b
it actually keeps the bird in a really
good shape
hot pan olive oil
seasoned
thyme pheasant
nice hot pan streaky bacon thyme
straight into the oven
red sauce
thyme salt pepper
[Applause]
[Music]
the big daddy black pepper pull in the
china shop
this is the one that actually brings it
all together
sweat milk
let it infuse bring it to the ball
slowly
back to pheasant baste that keeps
the pheasants really nice and moist
finish the sauce
sieve that milk is amazing bread crumbs
in butter
now we have a really nice smooth smart
sexy bread sauce
[Applause]
[Music]
okay pheasant rest 15 minutes and turn
it upside down because all the juices
from the top of the carkers
run into the bottom of the breast and so
by the time it's cooled down
it's full of flavour
[Music]
my whole leg just falls away
delicious present with bread sauce
done now with the pheasant i'm also
serving some red cabbage and we
we all grew up with this stuff pickled
in a jar but this is done in a very
simple form
it started on top of the stove it's got
butter in with it
and then we season it with brown sugar
over the cabbage and then tablespoon of
vinegar add that
to the brown sugar salt pepper
and then we braise it in the oven for
about 45 to 50 minutes so it cooks nice
and slowly
absorbs the vinegar the sugar
caramelizes it and makes it a really
nice
tasty cabbage now i'm serving devils and
horseback with a pheasant and that's
basically a prune that's been wrapped in
bacon
the sweetness and the saltiness of the
bacon goes brilliantly with a pheasant
cocktail stick
keep the bacon on there into a pan
get some really good color on the bacon
gets nice and crispy and that crispy
bacon with a sweet prune is amazing
now don't forget to take the cocktail
sticks out
before you serve them there it is yeah
five pheasant one ravioli yeah
journalist have watched that table
there's joan journalists
so the pheasant first then the ravioli
okay okay be very very careful yeah now
earlier today i set the commies a
challenge and that was to try and
separate the men
from the boys challenge time we got a
table of vegetarians in this evening now
vegetarian food has to be
just as exciting as the normal menu so
on this table in front of us we've got
an array of vegetables
i want you to think of a vegetarian
filling for a ravioli
think about it spinach ricotta sauteed
mushrooms rocket basil
you know just have a look you've got
half an hour let's go yes
[Music]
what's going through your mind what are
you doing cheese work and dog at the
same time we're against the clock you'd
like a fully booked restaurant yes
it's not just about your cheese and
tomatoes so what you're going to do
cheese tomato mozzarella okay is that
okay yeah that sounds nice and you're
going to season it with fresh basil
yeah hurry up yes
right russell what are you doing i'm
thinking of a open top ravioli
open top ravioli nice and what's in the
open top ravioli right i'm thinking sun
dried
then i've also got a roasted pepper
going on there
just give it that flavor just get get it
going i'm gonna put some blue cheese
into it as well
blue cheese as well yeah and as you know
we haven't got all day you know that
yeah yeah okay so move your ass yeah yep
yes sure okay
what are you gonna do i'm gonna do a
tomato and basil with a buffalo
mozzarella
okay you put the mozzarella in when it's
cooled down so it doesn't melt just so
it doesn't melt so we can just keep
those
solid cubes there yeah so as it starts
to cook in the ravioli it just slightly
melts inside
yeah okay good
looks like something i have a sci-fi
movie a taste tonight
well we'll find out won't we
[Music]
okay guys that's it let's go carry on
the hot plate russell let's go
phil kerry there want to stand next to
it
right uh russell
pastor stone cold you need to heat the
pasta up chef phil
he started blanching his pasta and you
followed suit
rather than you remaining as an
individual because your filling looked
nice
unfortunately so far i've got stone cold
pasta
overcooked pasta let's hope the last one
at least
has got something what's that the raw
sage leaf
no yeah we only put on a plate what we
can eat yeah never forget that
and look at that you can see why i don't
change nappies
insepared bland and nothing what i asked
for a simple ravioli unfortunately i'm
not going to serve
any of them in the restaurant by
vegetarians you know that tonight
get your [ __ ] together yeah clear down
all right let's go carry please yes uh
four pleasant away now
yeah four pheasant away now let's go oh
yeah
i don't understand what you're doing
kerry you're dropping your spoon you're
putting it back in your pocket
come on let's go
why are you asking me when you're
putting it on come on because i think we
do pheasant please now
peasants come on this is where it's
getting really tough now yes
yep down let's go
okay it's not cooked it's raw oh
the bacon's raw for god's sake
kerry come here a minute you it's raw
it is raw young lady you're going to
kill someone you can't serve raw bacon
not good enough not good enough take
your apron off and go
forget it out um right and start the
table again please
god's sake and start the table again
now it will soon be time to slaughter
the turkey so i've been trying to get
the kids ready
to say goodbye
we're a week away from slaughtering the
turkeys the children have been fattening
up for christmas
i'm getting worried that the kids are
getting too attached
oh well done let's have a look
is that anthony tilly loves cuddling
anthony and megan's been keeping her own
video diary
julie have been even more grumpy than
yesterday
i asked janice horton wallis from the
turkey club uk how to deal with it
her suggestion was rather radical you
may have to consider
possibly just keeping a couple back
so that then they they they think well
okay
yeah those go but we will still have
some turkeys here
will we get any turkey eggs they start
um mating properly in january or
february
and then the girls usually start laying
eggs about four weeks after the mating
process
they're very good layers and the eggs
are wonderful in baking
really oh they are definitely worth
trying like a duck egg or
they're not as strong as a duck egg
they're slightly larger than
a chicken's egg but they uh because of
the extra
album they're very good in pastry sauces
and things like that
and what about her indoors i gotta
explain that to her oh she'll love
eating their eggs
i'm not that convinced and i don't think
tana will be very enthusiastic either
she mentioned if the kids are getting
really sort of attached there is a
strong possibility we could
keep them or maybe keep half of them and
cook half
i think we've always been very honest
with them and this is what's happening
and i think they are
prepared for that and we stick to what
we originally planned i'm
you know happy to go along with what we
set out to do but i'm just asking you to
think about
an alternative we've done your project
i've supported you in that we've
fattened up the turkeys
and now you're backtracking because you
like them dean is shaking because you're
shouting so
you're upsetting let me go and sit over
with her you go sit with delia can't
believe
come on daley come on there have been
times when it's really
driven me crazy having the turkeys here
all the mess and everything like that
but it's been a fantastic learning curve
for the children
we've only got a couple of days left of
the turkeys and then they're going to be
slaughtered so i thought let's throw a
turkey party
they can explain to their friends
exactly what's going on and also it'll
really
put it clear in their minds that this is
happening and they won't sort of wake up
surprised to know that it's the final
day
we're eating them
[Music]
they're gonna kill jack's turkey first
yeah he's so
fat the kids actually seem fine about
killing the birds
but i need to know whether i've got
enough turkey to feed the diners at the
restaurant
so peter the vets going to do a final
weigh-in what are we doing
why so we can find out if they're fat
how fat they are we want them very fat
for christmas don't they
that's six kilos
[Music]
you need help lifting that one up wait
wait wait wait wait nigel
okay who's got the balance
turn who's next
[Music]
you're very good at this
[Music]
all right ainsley i know
seven kilos
who would like a sandwich you can't do
that
matt how are you evening chef good to
see you good to see you i'm not only
your wine writer but you're actually
jamie oliver's similar yep you're his
wine waiter at 15.
yep no you bought some wines absolutely
you thought we were going to go well
do you know what
but do you know what i think when it
comes to kind of food and wine matching
um you know i think a lot of people kind
of get unnecessarily kind of
you know confused with it and stressed
with it and they tend to think that you
know the best matches end up being
you know the most expensive matches and
it's not always the case definitely
definitely and um here i mean this is
the one word to describe this one is
that it's sexy
sexy you get kind of that sort of um
dark cherry yeah
get dark cherry you get a little bit of
spice but straight away you're getting
things like cinnamon
cloves yeah absolutely you know star
anise all the kind of things that you
use when you're cooking
the pheasant out there all those kind of
ingredients are starting to come through
and i guess that's one of the key things
when it comes to food and wine matching
yeah
you want to look for kind of like
similar sort of waste between food and
wine
you also want to look a similar similar
kind of intensity of flavor and keep it
sexy
absolutely now um you're highly
competitive yes i am i've got a test for
you okay
three of the most extraordinary wines i
want to try and tell me what you think
they are
there we go i'm not saying anything
[Applause]
he's gonna be something like blue nun
five quid
under
[Applause]
one of my favorites the heat is on big
boy
you should always trust your first
instincts and for me
first thing i sort of smell is kind of
cedar you know it's it's got there's a
fair bit of oak in there there's a fair
bit of fruit weight as well
um dark plum dark fruit you know
straight away i'm kind of thinking big
rich full body grape variety
probably thinking new world as well so
really okay
little taste huh
now the heat is on and you can see he's
looking nervous come on
that's turbocharged there's some muscle
and intensity behind that
that's kind of like it's awesome shiraz
or cabernet from probably from australia
here we go oh oh well done should i say
awesome
awesome churros well done thanks very
much huh
great okay you're ready yeah i'm ready
[Laughter]
okay instantly what you think what when
i look at this one
well i'm noticing the color the color is
nowhere near near as deep as the as the
previous one
sight's kind of probably the least
important of all your three senses you
know
yeah i mean you can close your eyes and
that's how i always find it a lot easier
what are you getting
about a very different league right
between that wine and this wine
okay so it's not giving away much on the
nose it's pretty flat
pretty dull soft
simple it's even a little bit corked
gordon i can't believe you put on a wine
that's just i would not
do that to you come on do you think it's
just a little bit caught
i'm not gonna argue with you i mean i
don't mind fighting but that's
definitely not cooked
you do the cooking i'll do the wine
oh god taxi okay have a little taste
god it's probably gonna be amazing
bordeaux or something like that isn't it
three two one we'll see if it's border
it's cabernet based wine from bordeaux
yeah what would you pay for it how much
would you pay for that 30 40 quid
30 40 quid you've been eating far too
many kangaroos you know that
that was a thousand pound bottle of a
[Laughter]
truce
[Music]
was it meatloaf that said two out of
three ain't bad
next on the menu it's pudding time sarah
beanie takes me on with a chocolate
brownie
also i think that putting nuts in it is
a bit like putting leeks in
macaroni cheese oh really it's just
wrong
charles goes in the sewer it's
disappearing into human [ __ ]
and devina has to sing for her supper
just an old sweet song
keeps georgia on
my mind
[Applause]
okay uh phil russell come here yeah
one's gone yes yes we've tried to put
raw bacon on a plate
now my brigade are leaving and you two
are gonna run the f-word restaurant
you've got a table of four and you've
got a table of four yeah yes hey
everything from bread source to cabbage
to pheasant yeah
mark out and out neil bye bye
let's go come on russell wakey wakey
bacon's burning she's already gone home
on the back of that let's go come on big
boy
nice and crispy little touch of butter
in there phil to finish it off with yeah
phil you got table 10 ready chef yes and
russell we got table 14 yes yes chef
well you know was talking to one another
hello we're in the same restaurant so
are you ready russ yeah how long you got
i'm ready mate you're here
move let's go yeah i'm looking for
presentation yeah each and every plate
looking exactly the same
let's go stand by table 14 stand by
look at each other's plates check that
we've got the same things going on
the same size portions yes yeah come on
don't forget it's the same restaurant
yes come on pheasant on first they're
last that's the garnish yes
there you go think about what you're
doing
come on russell a chef put the tray down
work with two hands it's twice as quick
right take your time don't spoil it now
yes
gently gently gently let's go
are you happy dirty plate i'm not happy
with that
hair there on the pheasant pull it out
come on wake up you got four eyes let's
go
up go table 14 go
right come here both of you well done
that's what it's like in the real world
that's one table each
out of 20 tonight clear down start again
well done chef
[Applause]
hello there nice to see you how are you
yeah well thank you how are you good
very well you enjoyed the pheasant yes i
did enjoy the present although i've got
something for you here
there's a bit of shocks that's great
news yeah so it was not one of those
posh birds it's a real
the combination of everything was really
good but the the professor was just
cooked to perfection
absolute perfection really lovely
hi how are you yeah well thank you good
to see you nice to see you
how was the pheasant it was very nice
yes very nice it could have been a
little bit more veg i felt
cool well i'm just saying you don't need
more veg without pheasants
and the devils and horseback and the red
swords and the devils on horseback were
pretty superb wonderful the way that it
was cooked this evening was fantastic it
fell off the bone
and the fact that the plate itself isn't
actually loaded with with
superfluous vegetables as well made it
very very nice time for pudding this
week sarah bean is going to try and beat
me with her favorite dessert
chocolate brownie now there's hundred
recipes of chocolate brownies and i'm
doing something quite sort of
unique some just delicious we're
finishing this time with some little
pecans
but this is not a big tray of chocolate
brownie they're going to be done in
little blini pans we're going to butter
them
line them with chocolate and cook them
individually almost like a little sort
of pancake but pancake chocolate brownie
this is a children's chocolate brownie
because i don't think you should put
extra bits in
it should just be pure chocolate brownie
this is really cheap so you can make it
if you're having masses of people to a
party
you can make it for loads of people we
had it at our wedding actually
not that i'm a cheap skate or anything
so get your brush
and lightly brush the inside of the pan
now all it is
is a block of chocolate break it in half
and just grate and just pour the
chocolate in there
and then roll it round right sarah
how are we doing this is cocoa sugar and
flour yep
and then this is the eggs and you just
pour it in there and that's it
that's it yeah well it doesn't taste
great i'm sure it does no chocolate in
there no
it's got it's got cocoa powder just
cocoa powder yeah and then i have to
grease the tin and that looks like
something you've nicked from your granny
um yeah and that goes in there and how
long does that cook for
25 minutes or maybe a bit more if it
doesn't look cooked
because it should be nice and crispy on
the outside and soft and gooey
that's the word you're a lady who likes
pressure you've got 37 guests coming
round
boxing day christmas day christmas day
yes that's a big table that 37. that is
a big takeaway you're cooking not
single-handedly surely
well sort of single-handed i've got this
turkey that's kind of
huge huge so have you got lots of
christmas i think we've got about
um 18 or 20. hey that's just as bad i
know
crazy so do you do lots of entertaining
then
i'm not very good at the dinner party
thing you know that it's not the kind of
thing i um i really enjoy doing to
totally honest
so this is why i couldn't be a cook
because i think this is taking ages
and it's really boring i'm thinking god
hurry up
how do you know so much about property
i've got a building company i do a boys
job you see you do girls job i do boys
i do a girl's job yeah that's the whole
gripe i wish women would get back in
there and do their job
you know that the women do make the best
chefs you know that i know well
obviously women do everything best no no
i'm not quite everything hello not quite
everything you're a bit of a matchmaker
aren't you i
am it is a bit of an obsession mine it
always has been actually
serious now did you do that over food
yeah well the best place to meet someone
is over food and booze
food and booze yes yes stick food and
booze and a few single people together
and they're going to get married
and what about someone like our resident
food critic i mean is there an is a
woman out there that's mad enough to
sort of date him
how would you describe him moany whingy
beardy short ass i think he definitely
gets someone
it definitely gets flipping egg now the
chocolate
and the butter has melted i've whisked
the eggs lightly
i've folded them in sarah's is going to
be slightly gungy in the center she said
sounds very ominous and mine of course
is going to be lined with like chocolate
buttons
and these little things pecans i have to
say
at this stage without getting too
carried away a damn time more appetizing
than sarah's
mind you i said that about the trifles
last week as well didn't i also i think
that putting nuts in it
is a bit like putting leeks in macaroni
cheese oh really it's just wrong
it's like ruining the purity i'm now
just going to lift that out and put them
in
for the moulds and then hopefully we'll
be ready
so when you fill the mold up two thirds
because they're gonna rise slightly and
then we leave it nice and soft and gooey
in the center those chocolate buttons
hopefully will be intact but slightly
runny i could have refurbished a five
bedroom house and the
time it takes to melt some butter like
half a smoothie this one's gonna eat it
and you've just got washing up to do
whilst you're uh pregnant okay and
obviously my wife's been pregnant three
times
i put weight on to make her feel happy
does it happen the same with you it's a
sweet tea
does he put weight on to make you feel
he is actually less fat in bed
no he does still say good god you're fat
every time i have no clothes seriously
so
which is true yeah to be honest no i'm
going to say confident now because it's
not cooked now let me have a quick look
at yours
okay just like the bike sheds you can
look at mine let me look at yours yeah
cheeky that's nice i've got to say you
yours does look like you cook for a
living and mine does it like i don't
and i desperately desperately
desperately need to win okay okay here
we go
it'll taste great though um i'm sure it
will we know that
[Applause]
hello charles hello gordon are you well
yeah i'm i'm not bad at all i'm happy at
least i've been fed
you've been fed yeah now what you've
been up to this week um i've been down a
sewer um i'm so used to
the healthy hygienic places like
professional kitchens bins squirrels
kebabs
and but no but that was because i was
investigating food here i was
investigating quite the opposite
i was i was up to my up to my elbows in
uh in [ __ ]
seriously um yeah and it's because of
the fat that gets thrown away
fat is a huge problem in britain i'm not
talking about fat people i'm talking
about cooking fat
when you flush them away down the sewers
as we all do sometimes they'll cool
solidify and harden and cause blockages
and when that happens
we're in big trouble last year alone we
spent 15 million pounds clearing our
pipes
and 3 000 properties were flooded as a
result of blockage
with christmas approaching the water
companies are expecting a 25
increase in the amount of fat that we're
flushing down our drains which means
that we're going to be adding over
christmas to an already existing problem
in the underbelly of our cities but what
does that really mean
i'm not dressed up like this just
because it looks sexy it's cause i'm
gonna go down there
and find out
well i understand the issues about this
fat being thrown away but it looks all
fairly harmless when it goes down the
sink so
what does it look like here i don't
understand well you'll soon see joel's
when you get around this corner here
oh it smells nasty now if i drown or
something are you gonna do mouth to
mouth
you won't drown what's this that's uh
that's the fat what you're gonna go into
that's fat yeah it's fat out of people's
kitchens gone down the sink and
yeah oh no oh and there's things sitting
in there oh [ __ ] and it's everywhere
cheers but if i need a radioactive
anti-thingy
death suit just be careful of you oh god
the chefs of the world who would love to
see me disappear under there
ah it's disappearing into human [ __ ]
you got some sanitary towels why am i
doing this
i don't know there is that's your fat
that's
it turkey roast your lovely grannies and
grandchildren come around
you cook that up for them and you toss
it down the sink without a thought he
comes down here
solidifies and people like kenny have to
walk up and down and they're shoveling
it up and throwing it away it's
absolutely disgusting i'm i'm
i probably knew that already i didn't
need to come down here to prove it but
we'll do it again
uh well this is the third shower i've
had since i got back from the sewer and
i haven't got close to removing the
smell having seen the scale of the
problem though
i promise you i'm determined to find out
what we can do about it
so i've discovered a clever little
device you can use at home fat tramps
which is a thing like this that you
leave by the sink
instead of throwing your used fat down
the sink
you just pour it into there in this
manner
you put some nuts in it you give it a
shake to make a lovely little feast and
you put it out for the birds or in fact
if you haven't got one of those you can
do the same thing with a
baked bean tin apparently if we all do
this if we all use these fat traps and
stop throwing our stuff down the sinks
we can make a huge difference to the
state of our sewers and drains
having said that restaurants and fast
food joints to the biggest fatty
villains and they also need to shape up
by law they're obliged to have waste fat
collected although thousands of them are
still illegally pouring it down the
drain
but some councils are fighting back
they're collecting the fat for free
and turning it into diesel for cars
so i've got a gallon here of delightful
waste cooking oil from the f-word
restaurant which i bought into my garden
because it's the last thing i want in my
house
uh because i've got a fellow here who
reckons he can turn it into uh
into car fuel yeah what we're doing is
we're converting it into biodiesel
and so how much will our gallon of
f-word waste cooking fat
make how much diesel one gallon of used
cooking oil you'll get one gallon of
biodiesel so do you need to do anything
to the engine of your car to make this
stuff work in it if you've got a
properly produced biodiesel it's a
direct replacement you have to modify
things you're saying i just throw into
the drum that's used fat yeah literally
pour it in slightly green
ah and then i just hit hit this this
green button here pump on
correct is that it is as no i need to
add caustic soda and methanol
okie dokie so i pop that in the hopper
here
and start pumping the methanol over and
how long does this take to make it takes
about an hour mixing and then it's that
easy and then hey presto we have
biodiesel hey presley have biodiesel
pump it into your car and you can drive
on
and here it comes real diesel although
that said
uh i think i'm first gonna have to put
it in the car and go for a drive just to
make absolutely sure it works
do you think i can just put this
straight in the car you just pour it
straight in
in it goes
right here then it's the moment of truth
will the car start
hurrah it has i didn't believe it would
it's amazing it smells it
smells more like a chip shop than a car
though um i have a gallon of gordon's
used
fat in this car and given that it's as
good as diesel
uh that will get me if i head north from
my home as far as
luton well lucky me
excited yeah yeah this is gonna be
fantastic this is uh
i'm actually slightly nervous oh no is
it burnt i know it's got a nice crack on
the top oh
okay now how you're going to serve yours
i'm going to serve it in slices like a
cake
yeah you just want yeah send it like
that and give them a spoon
but the difficulty is you have to make
them with all sort of posh stuff in
don't you
not at all chocolate buttons that's not
posh you can finish mine with a touch of
creme fraiche
this is called a blob that's called a
blob nice
are you happy with that jean baptiste um
take sarah's upstairs first okay
yes yes and if they don't like it we can
line their lofts with some new cavity
wall insulation
yeah can i just say it's bloody heavy
honestly it feels like one of your
breeze blocks from one of your buildings
hello how are you guys hello what's he
so danny
this is number one
i like the texture on the top as well
like the kind of crunch it's kind of
nice and gooey in the middle and it's
like nice kind of crunchy
outside because
might be slightly too gooey actually
just if i was going to
add some constructive criticism to that
but i find it i like the gooeyness
because
it makes it quite contrast from the
crust
okay daddy this is this number two okay
thank you wow
i'm not sure about this one i'm not sure
about the cream yeah it's the cream it's
quite dry actually isn't it it's quite
flaky on the top
i shouldn't be overconfident about you
know the brownies at this stage but i
have to say i bloody adam you know that
because if i lose this challenge this
week honestly i'm gonna say
oh i will start liking andrew roll
thompson that's how confident i am i'm
gonna win
yeah i think i've had enough of that one
yeah yeah
ali jb what so this week the winner is
yes
well done sarah oh get out with us
pissing around oh no sarah won yes
i'll get it again really sorry the
result you know that i'm gonna go
upstairs
to the judges where are they
yeah i'm glad you find it funny um just
out of interest i mean
taste that again for me okay yeah all of
you and then i can
start with the lady at the end now
tell me what you're tasting
it tastes bitter bitter yeah it's quite
kind of like almost
burnt taste to it burnt yes
look out look look just look how wet
that is in the center in the middle but
you're going to get through the dry
outside to get to the middle
i you know i i don't understand it just
slightly too dry
yeah it's like i'm sorry all three of
you can off out of here now as well yes
dear oh dear useless
i'm not gonna serve it i'm gonna serve
my chocolate brownie my restaurant
my customers and and my reputation on
the line that's that
and that's it i'm really sorry but no it
is okay because you do think this is
food
no it's just it you know it's not it's
not bad but it's not good come here
let me get around that bump oh sent out
here like this well done well done
next on the menu i rediscovered
britain's most underrated but delicious
meat
by you i'd have it any day and phil and
russell find out which one of them is
staying
and who's going home one of you is a
follower
and one of you is a creator
[Applause]
right sarah yes i know it's not your
dessert but you can still yeah
get the pan do you want me to pick the
nuts out make it better i don't mind you
picking my nuts at all for god's sake
like a knife i do yeah it stuck you see
mine didn't stick
so ah send that to joel
please now oh my god
oh no look at the buttons in mine
yeah see disappointing really isn't it
i'm glad you think so thanks so much
chocolate bruni with creme fraiche can
you just say that for me one more time
chocolate chocolate boonie with creme
crush
oh my god that was so cute a chocolate
broody
ladies enjoy your chocolate brownie
very succulent and lovely kind of
dessert you want to take the bed right
perfect i can tell you it's on the
outside and soft on the inside yes
and you've got a little bit of chocolate
dripping down here and it's perfect
this week i'd be looking at one of
britain's tastiest but sadly
most unfashionable meats once upon a
time mutton was a very reasonably priced
meat that everyone ate
before it fell off the kitchen radar and
not only do you want to see it back in
restaurants back on their menus but
at home as well because this is part of
our culinary heritage
mutton is a meat from a sheep that's at
least two years old it's rarely sold in
supermarkets and can be hard to get your
hands on
these days most of our mutton gets eaten
in europe when was the last time you had
mutton
years ago years ago and who cooked it my
grandmother it's a bit sort of
old-fashioned and a beer
it's not very sort of sexy is it modern
i've never eaten mine at all
ever he's a cheap car me most people now
earn more money they buy better cuts
than me
it looks like mutt has been completely
forgotten so why did mutton disappear
totally financial in the 1940s
the imports from australia and new
zealand came
um the price of lamb and wool went down
and it wasn't worth farmers keeping
use for more than a single season so it
wasn't about the flavor
it it's just about the price of wolves
absolutely why should the british public
out there
be eating more mutton because it's been
extensively grazed it cannot be factory
farmed it's the wildest and most natural
meat that we can possibly eat and one of
the most delicious
to produce the best mutton sheep need a
diet of good green grass
and correct treatment once they've been
slaughtered a mutton carcass should be
hung whole for around about two weeks
the meat is extraordinary it's amazing
the difference in mutton and lamb how
dark it is
and it's surrounded by a lot more fat
you can deal with that you know in in
the cooking process
you can use the same cuts as you do in
lamb from mutton
and what's the price of mutton now it's
about half the price of lamb
and twice as much flavor someone at home
cooking for the first time what would
you recommend
oh i'd say i'd say the diced the dice
that'll be the one that's diced up ready
now for a stew ready to go
mutton has a reputation for being
slightly tough and the secret behind
this particular dish is
the length of the cooking time so what
i'm cooking here is the simplest of
mutton stews
generous for the seasoning run it
through some flour shake it
and into the pan so what we'll do now is
put some flavor on it
[Music]
once it's browned into the colander and
just leave it to drain
vegetables now this is a stew so we
don't have any little sort of
fine dices garlic just in there in half
celery the leeks frigger rosemary
and a nice sprig of thyme peppercorns
lightly crush them tomato puree roast it
off
half bottle of house red wine take your
mutton
mix that in pour boiling hot water on
top
so that's it two and a half hours on a
low gas perfect
it's ready now let's see if we can
convert
south london to mutton you want me to
know that kind of spell cooked the
mountain
that is delicious oh it's lovely you
enjoy that
cooked by you i'd have it any day
am i allowed tomorrow promise me you'll
try a mutton stew this weekend
deal deal so come on you not give mutton
a go it is a tasty meat and let's be
honest
it does deserve a second chance
[Applause]
how's your brownie can i just tell you
what i love corn see that that's really
runny
oh yeah there's a little chocolate
buttons inside they're runny they get
off that's mine
[ __ ] shower no romantic dishwasher
there's only one thing that i don't do
and that's to share my footings
your background in food you lived in
paris i lived in paris and you worked
part-time there
i did i did i was oh god i was a singing
waitress
but can i just say very good waitress so
karaoke was in that long ago
serious that was good that's fine you
ever need
i can't believe you're doing that with
your finger underneath there
and spoon on to that jimmy car's in
tonight yes
where is he oh there he is there he is
there
set up right looking nice
now he presented last year the hundred
worth quickens yeah i came 82nd
and you came 95th was a bit out did i
yes now that you've told me that yes
i'll name him as well later as well
yeah i'm going to get him to catapult
school yeah big time
he actually sits like a little public
school boy over there isn't it he's like
he's
talking about you
[Laughter]
oh god
first of all to both of you well done
one step away from working with me
personally phil
how bad do you want it
um the knowledge i'd learn after you go
and just be unreal and it's a case of i
want to soak up all the knowledge
you can teach me so i can take it away
and then open my own restaurant
um russell how bad do you want it i want
it really bad this is what i'm trying to
train for and just to have that chance
and like nothing like this ever happens
to me um
literally being a whole small town
chinese lad in the take away to this
what more can i say it's a tough
decision for me
however there's one big difference
between you both
this evening because one of you
is a follower and one of you
is a creator and phil
you followed russell
and that's the reason why you're going
home tonight i'm really sorry
thank you keep going i will do
yes yes chef you cheers get some sleep
yeah yeah yeah get your [ __ ] together
thank you chef
you